bonsoir et bienvenue sur tv fil 78 pour
ce nouveau 7,8 une heure pour faire le
point sur l'actualité locale dans un
instant vous allez découvrir les
principaux titres de ce 10 octobre mais
déjà bonsoir johan un bon soir comme
chaque mercredi votre chronique culture
aux alentours de 18h30 ce soir si vous
nous suivez en direct
oui nous allons nous intéresser aux
spectacles à découvrir celui en cours à
la ferme de bel ébat également la grange
de la tramblais sur bois d'arcy pour ce
week-end et les semaines à venir
à tout à l'heure johanna rendez vous je
vous le disais vers 18h30 on passe à
présent aux principaux titres de ce 10
octobre le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines sera construit
fin 2013 avec une piste olympique le
site accueillera aussi un terrain de bmx
et le siège de la fédération française
de cyclisme pour symboliser l'avancée du
chantier une visite était organisée avec
notamment des champions olympiques tels
que grégory baugé que vous allez
entendre tout à l'heure la fête de la
science c'est en ce moment comment
vulgariser la science auprès des plus
jeunes
exemple avec le laboratoire latmos au
sein de l'université de versailles saint
quentin un reportage et un invité en
plateau à partir de lundi démarre à
saint quentin en yvelines une semaine
consacrée à l'allaitement maternel c'est
bien fait ces contraintes aussi pour
bien comprendre
rencontre avec une coordinatrice en
lactation installé à montigny le
bretonneux votre logement est il bien
isolé pour le savoir une étude a été
menée sur l'agglomération chaque
appartement maison locale d'activité a
été photographiée pour connaître son
degré de thermographie les résultats de
l'étude ont été publiés
après valérie pécresse c'est un autre
député et ancien ministre yvelinois qui
a décidé de soutenir françois fillon est
david douillet votre à pour l'ancien
premier ministre au moment de choisir le
nouveau
10dans de l'ump il dit ne pas avoir
apprécié les récentes déclarations de
jean françois copé sur le racisme anti
blanc il a aussi a déclaré à nos
confrères du parisien qu'il était contre
le cumul des mandats et qu'il ne serait
pas tête de liste à poissy lors des
municipales en 2014 david douillet
participera au prochain meeting de
françois fillon à marseille dès jeudi
soir
je vous le disais la semaine de
l'allaitement maternel va démarrer à
saint quentin en yvelines en yvelines
quel bienfait et quelles contraintes
voici quelques réponses
un personnel hospitalier déborder un
congé maternité cours et des femmes qui
travaillent autant de raisons qui freine
la mise au sein des bambins et même si
la france reste à la traîne
certaines femmes vont jusqu'au bout de
leur désir d'alerter et assument leur
choix comme c'est maman rencontrée lors
d'une réunion à versailles
c'était familial à la base 100 toute ma
famille à l'été et puis après j'ai
compris que c'était plus simple pour le
lever et puis plus naturel ça lui
donnait tout et puis bon en tant que
jeune je pense qu'on est tous les trois
là on se connaît tous fatigués quand
même un aspect budget c'est bête mais ça
fait réfléchir
je me voyais pas faire autrement en fait
c'était
dans la continuité de la grossesse et
voilà pour créer du lien avec ma fille
pour je sais pas france et elle est
naturelle naturelle mais pas aussi
simple que ça les études démontrent que
les femmes qui font le choix de
l'allaitement ont pour la plupart c'est
des études supérieures et sont
indépendantes
difficile alors de concilier réussite
professionnelle et vie de famille
pourtant certaines y parviennent elles
seront capables de dire mais moi ça me
plaît et je veux le beurre et l'argent
du beurre c'est à dire je veux continuer
mon métier reprendre mon travail
continuer à allaiter mon enfant et elle
ne se laisse pas abattre par exemple à
la reprise du travail afin d'être mieux
informés les futures mamans se tourner
vers des associations spécialisées ou
écoute et échanges d'expériences les
rassure dans l'agglomération des
animations et des rencontres sont
proposées autour de ce thème du 15 au 21
octobre